I'll go my name is Pam Pat welcome back
to the new ending of em I replayed the
game to hopefully get the good ending
I'm really holding my thumb's here like
I don't want to do all that again
just for all right here we go well once
you green there's no going back all your
time here will be lost you don't know
one of the words all right what's this
big mural of fabricated world hey isn't
that the former gallery does that mean
if we jump into this we'll go back there
but how are we meant to jump into a
painting that frame what ah yep look the
frame now might be a go Garrett go yeah
yeah I'm really in hurry up head go head
[ __ ] do it
let's run come on em what are ya doin
what is that bench doing that I finally
found you
geez I was looking everywhere don't just
go running around place up now your
father's waiting for you to you see
you're fake you're fake [ __ ] what are
you doing come over how many times have
I told you don't go following strangers
hey it's not scared okay I'll be fine
you'll be fine
hey listen to your mother don't go with
some stranger do you do you want to
never see your mother and father again
I'll pull you over come with me grab my
hat
ah [ __ ] f go with Gary of course [ __ ] up
[ __ ] ie alright
the problem now is if whether we
remember it or not I guess I can only
help question mark you can't remember
what you were doing [ __ ]
alright yeah
music again did it ever now you are Gary
Gary what's your down good hmm what is
today ah he doesn't remember us what are
you looking at well let's see it's a
real say sure I guess when I look at the
sculpture I feel somehow sorrowful I
wonder why [ __ ] I'm sorry if I said
anything to trouble you
never mind what I said well bye there
you are yet oh are you looking at this
wow this is really great it represents a
person's heart I suppose I wonder if you
have such a beautiful rose in your heart
let's take a look around have you looked
anything else I hope we find some more
things you like oh my
ah [ __ ] what did I do wrong what is this
stupid ending I press I will try to do
the new ending see in a second
don't intend entertained and today who's
there
yep Gary we're both okay how did you get
into that room leave Mary you don't take
another step
wha Lee right now now now Holly
I swear to God I click [ __ ] all right
good thing I saved there though okay
okay please please just please please
please please please face face face face
face please please
please please
please work please work please work
all right so Gary cut himself if and she
offered please panty I have to say girls
sure can be scary yeah well anyway I'd
burn up a lot more violent than expected
are you okay bhagath please hmm mmm my
hand oh you're right I caught it I don't
even notice it must have happened done
give the handkerchief Chen that is the
thing then we gives us the good ending
yes may I use it yes you [ __ ] maze in
this the relays well I don't
particularly want to tarnish this too
late unfortunately how well I'll borrow
this anyway thanks it let's get going
oh yeah let's go watch how the good
ending is thank Jesus oh man that was
that was I thought I was gonna have to
replay it all again and add Alain I
don't know that was just too much for me
all right let's get through this why
it's Sark watch your step head watch
that I should what are you talking about
what's that
all right here we go through depending
again we're back at the gallery this
place looks familiar
because we've been here before all right
the thing is I don't know how we will
remember how if they go through the
painting maybe then we go somewhere else
or some [ __ ] like that I guess we got to
go out anyway once it go in there's no
going back
old timing that who lost you don't know
the other words
there we go hey isn't that the former
galley does that mean we can jump in
watch em lock the frame now might be our
chance
nice jump Gary yes I'm reeling please
some time without fish is gonna arrive
what is she doing there what are you
doing yeah by phallic [ __ ] off
you're not real yep
don't go [ __ ] he saw a stranger okay
it's my friend [ __ ] all right em go
with Gary all right
please time it worked please tell me boy
I wanted to work so bad so so bad I want
the good ending please you can't
remember what you were doing all right
let's go find Gary
Gary Gary come on sit down my Gary okay
is that my parents I wonder if I have as
I talked to them and if you have to use
at all you can just go okay okay oh yes
please remember me hmm what is it little
lady what do you what are you looking at
well let's say it's a real sculpture I
guess when I look at this sculpture I
feel under why ah I'm sorry if I said
something to trouble you in what who's
him what what's your name
that's your name your that's the
strangest thing I mean I don't know you
at all it just kinda came out how odd
but actually have a perhaps met
somewhere before
mmm my look at me asking you such
strange things never mind what I said
well nine hmm what is this a hankerchief
when did I get this remember me Gary
ah this is yours my word it's true em
their name right on it but why is it in
my pocket
plus there's blood um oh here a map
bears a lot of the guys starting in the
background oh I was I was wounded on the
hand and a girl a girl gave me her
handkerchief
yes this handkerchief was given to me as
a gift it was a gift from him I remember
now
we were together back there how could I
forgotten it was so important we stuck
together through that bizarre gallery
chase by strength stuttered and married
to right
Abdo you remember I remember ah thank
goodness it's hard to believe even now
but I must have happened right if we got
back safely we did it
haha remember there's so much more I
want to talk about but I've got to get
going
ah it's alright if I keep this
handkerchief a while longer
I wouldn't do to return it as it is I'll
have to make it clean and give it back
you can keep Gary because we will see
each other again ah that gosh yeah
that's right yes we did it Bros ready
[ __ ] get it as well you got three
endings in this playthrough so you can't
complain I guess thanks for all this
part in this series I'm gonna start on
you let's play tomorrow and it's not
gonna be it's not gonna be hard but it's
gonna be similar to it because I know a
lot of people want I guess I don't know
I counted like that it was more story
story based
more stuff like that anyway like favors
you enjoyed subscribe home-brewed today
and I'll see you next epic whenever I
[ __ ] finish alright I'm trying I'm
talking about everything i [ __ ]
ha what happened